This episode of Dnews was proudly made possible
the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
It’s not just a Sedan, it’s a Subaru.
Scientists have discovered a way to cure certain
pesky bacterial infections - and the treatment
is a pill full of poop.
Literally.
Kinda wish I was making that up.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - in amazing
disgusting science revelations - researchers
have discovered that capsules full of frozen
poop may actually save your life!
Clostridium difficile, also known as C diff,
is an extremely stubborn bacterial infection
that can cause severe debilitating diarrhea.
It typically occurs after someone takes antibiotics
for an unrelated illness.
Those antibiotics wipe out all of the normal
flora in their gut, allowing C diff to essentially
overrun the intestines.
It’s a growing problem in health care facilities,
killing nearly 14,000 people a year in the
US alone.
And it’s notoriously difficult to treat.
Most antibiotics don’t work against it,
because it’s an infection specifically brought
on by taking antibiotics.
But there is one thing that’s been shown
effective for patients suffering from extreme
C diff infections: fecal transplants.
And yes, that is exactly what it sounds like.
The idea here, is that you take someone else’s
poop - someone healthy, usually a relative
- and implant it into your body via colonoscopy,
after which it replenishes all of your good
gut bacteria.
Obviously, that’s a tricky process.
So researchers at Massachusetts General Hospital
tried coming up with better ways to do it.
First, they tried delivering the transplant
through a tube that goes down your nose and
into your stomach - which worked, but again
- not really ideal.
Especially since if a patient gagged or vomited
during the procedure, they could potentially
inhale fecal matter - which sounds like literally
the worst thing ever.
So they came up with another idea - that’s
so simple, it’s kind of amazing no one thought
of it before.
They just put it in a pill!
They figured patients would be way less likely
to vomit from it, and by freezing the pills,
they wouldn’t need anyone to make a “fresh
donation.”
They could just keep them in a freezer.
What’s hilarious though, is that the capsules
themselves have to be acid-resistant in order
make it past the stomach and into the intestines
- and unfortunately, the only acid-resistant
capsules on the market - are translucent.
Which is… not ideal.
Of course if you have a C diff infection,
I’m guessing that’s a small price to pay
for relief.
So they put the pills into production, and
tested them on a group of 20 people with recurrent
C. diff infections.
Each of those patients was instructed to take
30 pills over the course of 2 days.
And miraculously, 14 of them experienced immediate
relief from diarrhea - with no recurrences
whatsoever.
The other 6 tried the treatment again, and
for 4 of them - it worked the second time
around.
The two people who failed to see any improvements
were found to be in poorer overall health.
Since that initial test run, doctors have
treated 21 additional patients, with similar
success.
But that doesn’t necessarily preclude anything
bad from happening.
It’s possible that this method could actually
transmit other infectious agents - so for
now, doctors are relegating it to only the
most extreme cases.
What do you guys think?
Would you rather eat 30 pills full of someone
else’s feces, or have diarrhea for 4 months
straight?
Let us know what you think in the comments
below - and as always, thank you guys for
watching!